In 1993 Steven Spielberg directed
Schindler's list.
The film he considers the most important
of his career.
The movie shows his mastery of visual
imagery.
Perhaps the most famous symbol in this
movie is the little girl in the red coat
wandering aimlessly during the
liquidation of the Krakow ghetto.
Spielberg said she symbolizes how
obvious the Holocaust was.
Yet nobody did anything to stop it.
It was always obvious as a little girl
wearing a red coat walking down the
street.
When he talks about the scene,
he mentions the impact of having a color
show up in the middle of a black and
white movie,
but he doesn't mention the color itself,
which begs the question,
why does red work so well in this scene?
If all that matters is having color show
up in black and white,
the symbolism wouldn't be the same if
her coat was blue,
but blue drastically changes the feeling
of the scene as would any other color.
Each color is packed with its own
symbolism.
Filmmakers may not know all the nuances
of a colors,
history and meaning,
but they understand each colors
emotional payoff.
So what symbolism is unique to the color
red.
Why do some filmmakers make such
pointed?
Careful use of red.
The color definitely has a very unusual
biological effect on humans.
It evokes all sorts of passionate
emotions.
When we feel angry,
embarrassed,
or flirtatious,
we literally get red in the face.
If two boxers of equal skill fight each
other,
the one in red is actually more likely
to win.
Several studies suggest that it's the
color people look most attractive
wearing.
There's even an urban legend that red
cars are more likely to get pulled over.
Red stands out amongst other colors,
and filmmakers have always understood
this phenomenon.
The screenwriters of the wizard of Oz
wanted to show off the beauty of
technicolor,
so they had to change the plain silver
slippers from the novel the sought after
and powerful slippers did not become
emeralds green or bright yellow.
One color suited them best.
If something is important,
read gets the job done on its own.
We use the color red to indicate
anything in the real world that has been
tainted by the other world.
And red is you specifically to connote
really explosively emotional moments and
situations.
It's no surprise that red is mankind's
original color.
Not only was it the first color used in
art in cave paintings,
but nearly every western language has a
name for it before any other color
before Newton's rainbow.
Early philosophers put red in the middle
of the color spectrum directly in
between black and white,
so it's no surprise that many filmmakers
have an instinct to place black,
white,
and red together.
It seems like reducing the color
spectrum exponentially enhances the
symbolic weight of these three colors.
Snow White,
the evil queen,
dressed in black,
the red apple,
but I think to really get at the meaning
of such a unique and important color and
why a scene like in Schindler's list
would use it.
We have to look at its historical
significance.
The perception of color is not just a
biological phenomenon but a cultural one
and it's symbolic.
Power comes from two objects,
fire and blood,
two elements always associated with red
and universally encountered by every
society throughout history.
Even today,
whenever a dictionary defines red,
they typically use fire and blood in
their explanation.
The relationship between red and blood
makes sense.
Since all living vertebraes,
half dried blood,
but the association of red with fire is
less clear after all,
fire isn't exactly read but more of an
orange or yellow.
Why do we culturally link read it with
the color of fire?
Historians argue it's because many
ancient societies soft fire as a living
being it's domestication was the
symbolic birth of civilization and like
the Sun.
It is a source of life by providing
light and heat.
Blood and fire were always at the center
of early religious traditions.
Animal blood sacrifices were thought to
lead to good harvest and many beliefs.
Fire was passed down from the gods like
when prometheans stolen in Greek
mythology.
A key component of these two elements is
there symbolism of both life and death.
On one hand,
fire keeps you warm,
protects you from predators and lights
up your home,
but once it's out of control,
fire leads to death and destruction.
Similarly,
blood is a source of human life,
but the sight of blood indicates injury
and too much means death.
Christian stories clearly reflect our
ancient contradictory relationships with
fire and blood.
On one hand,
God uses fire to communicate with Moses
three burning Bush,
but fire also symbolizes the eternal
tormenting of hell,
explaining why hell is always read.
What does represent Jesus as gruesome
crucifixion,
but cardinals reappropriated that
meaning it to something positive by
wearing red as a symbol of Jesus's blood
sacrifice.
Red Symbolism varies wildly depending on
the time and place,
but it always ties back to these core
elements.
Red is a symbol of love and passion,
but it also became a symbol of
prostitution and illicit sex in the
middle ages,
showing the pitfalls of too much passion
of getting too close to the flame,
so to speak.
Red was the symbol of the French
revolution and from that on the color
became a sign of extreme political
upheaval.
Oftentimes,
violet always passionate,
aggressive,
and filled with life.
The point is,
if a critic looks at read through the
Lens of its origins in fire in blood,
then the symbolic power of red becomes
much more obvious.
Many movies used red to tap into these
powerful historical roots.
Red is heat.
It is a symbol of life and light in an
otherwise desolate and cold world.
It adorns energetic,
youthful characters.
What's Anderson gloves?
It because injects visual life into his
scenes.
Retta often sexualizes female characters
echoing it's association with love and
lust,
but sometimes red goes to,
are you listening to me?
Neil,
what were you looking at?
The woman in the red dress I was with
again,
as much as red indicates life,
it just as easily signals death and
horror.
What was one's passion becomes obsession
to the point of self destruction.
No color better captures youth and
sexuality and the boys have a clockwork
orange represent this sexuality to a
dangerous extreme.
Sometimes a red car is just an easy way
to indicate speed,
but it sometimes goes deeper than that.
Cameron's dad loves his red car to the
extreme more so than even his own son.
The Carton Boyz in the hood is a
illuming sign of death that appears out
of nowhere.
The idea that there is no escape for
these characters gets reinforced in the
opening shot.
An example of red as the color of
warning and danger movies also channeled
the religious significance of the color
in mean streets.
Charlie holds his hand over flames in a
form of personal penance,
a nod to his fear of the flames of hell.
It's no coincidence that Tony's Bart is
bathed in red and indication at the
place contains sex,
blood and violence.
Uh,
world's Charlie wants to escape.
Perhaps the most powerful use of red is
when filmmakers can juxtapose.
It's positive and negative symbolism
showing the two kinds of red side by
side.
The ending of don't look now has a
bizarre montage revealing the true
identity of the girl in the red coat.
Part of the horror of the finale is the
contrast of different classic red
images.
That youthful coat followed by his
blood,
then sex and even a flames in a church.
All these images mixed together.
Disorients the viewer through the
unusual pairings of Red Schindler's list
perfectly embodies all the symbolic uses
of red.
It's origins in fire and blood.
The religious significance developed
from pagan rituals all the way to
Christianity and the harnessing of the
colors,
dual meanings.
The movie begins with the lighting of a
flame.
As a Jewish family celebrates,
the sabbath color fades away when the
fire goes out and the story descends
into Krakow,
Poland during World War II,
right from the beginning,
the film establishes fire as a symbol of
Jewish tradition and to the
extinguishing of the flame for shadows,
the end of Jewish life in Poland,
the recurring flames throughout the
movie symbolize both danger and life.
In one scene,
Spielberg super imposes a burning flame
on to Oskar Schindler's chests to
symbolize his gradual transformation
from a greedy businessman to a
benevolent savior.
The flames of his factory are a source
of life as he saves Jewish people from
extermination.
In contrast to the flames from the
pressure of labor camp burn bright and
harsh in the foreground as the Nazis
walk into the factory in the background.
A reminder of the death and destruction
they bring with them at their most
extreme flames are associated with
horrific mass graves.
But when Schindler invites his Jewish
workers to practice the sabbath,
the flames become color.
Once again in Schindler's factory,
the Jewish tradition can continue.
He provides light in a world surrounded
by darkness.
Flames are at the same time a symbol of
the Jewish people surviving and a symbol
of their destruction.
In this movie,
blood and death also go hand in hand
with numerous executions and murders,
but once he uses blood in a more subtle
but equally disturbing way,
when the Nazis want to separate the
healthy from the sick,
a group of women in the camp apply their
own blood as makeup.
They're using blood to try to appear
more alive.
It's such a cruel irony that they have
to bleed to look more lively so they can
intern.
Avoid a bloody death.
Self harm is a form of self preservation
in comparison to the rest of the movie.
This moment may seem benign,
but it perfectly captures the absurdity
of the Holocaust.
How life and death were so disturbingly
intertwined.
Blood is death and life all at once.
The red code is an incredible summation
of all these ideas.
On one hand,
the little girl is youth life and
innocence.
The red calls attention to her fiery
warmth and young blood,
but once she hides under the bed,
her redcoat loses its color and we see
it later in a whole new deadly context.
The code is now presumably red with
blood to be disposed of in Schindler's
list,
and the girl in the code are the story
of the color red.
They are a story of death and life
coexisting together.
The red of Oskar Schindler is the bread
of life surrounded by his red is the red
of the Holocaust.
Well,
this is life.
It's margins nice to company.
Not every instance of the color is as
extreme as Schindler's list,
but an overt uses of read the same
symbolic principles apply.
It has a powerful and primal response
for the viewer coming from the human
understanding of blood and fire.
Filmmakers don't necessarily have
knowledge of the actual symbolic history
of different colors,
but the best ones definitely know how to
use it.
Long before directing artists understood
the strengths of different colors.
If a calvinist painter wanting to give
prominence to someone in their painting,
all they had to do was add a red sash.
Any artist can benefit from knowing the
various strengths and weaknesses of each
color.
Olympia's on Yolie is an incredible
graphic designer who harnesses bolts,
colors in her illustrations.
If you want to learn the secrets of
using color in your graphic design,
you can sign up for her class on
skillshare.
Skillshare has over 20,000 classes on a
ton of topics from design to business.
The first 500 people to click on the
link in the description,
we'll get two months of completely free
access to skillshare.
That's the graphic design class,
plus thousands of others from marketing
and video editing to photography.
Thanks for watching,
and a big thank you to skillshare for
sponsoring this video.